i remember when everything started
getting crazy during covet and the lines
were out the door
and it was like all of a sudden like
run-of-the-mill liberals
were trying to buy guns and the funniest
thing about it was how many of them
realized it wasn't easy
like oh no especially in california yeah
i hear it's like not
impossible yeah to buy weapon to buy a
gun in california what's the process
i hadn't tried because i knew i wasn't
going to be able to do it but i know
that for one the stores were
many of them were closed or if they i
think you have to apply
but um what many of us do is just
we consider going to like my home state
of idaho or nevada
and the process is a lot easier and then
you're able to bring it back to
california oh sure you just have to
register the weapon when you get to
california oh interesting a lot of
states do operate that like that
you know if you already have it or if
you bought it somewhere else illegally
then they don't care if you have it yeah
so it is weird and
you know in that capacity there are a
lot of people who are staunchly like
absolute 2a absolutist and i have to say
from like a legal perspective i don't
see a way around this argument
like we know we we we talk about michael
malus too much michael we're talking
about you too
he's just gotta look that's coming up
yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys because
romance going
you know no it's because he's a smart
guy and he made a really good point he
said
that the constitution says i have a
right to keep and bear arms
but every single cop in new york city
would arrest me if i had a gun and i'm
like
i mean the constitution is the law of
the land it says you that the right to
keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed it
doesn't say if you're mentally ill you
can't have a weapon it doesn't say if
you're a felon you can't have a weapon
it literally is just a verbatim you can
have a weapon
yeah i get because it's the open carry
or it's the concealed carrier open carry
laws right
so all of a sudden now there's like look
new jersey you can't
you absolutely you can own the weapon
but you can't
go anywhere with it you can't bear it
well that's right so that's the big
question is what does bear mean
does it yeah but i and i would think
that burying arms
i guess we'd have to look back at what
did they mean by the word bearing
you know bear arms back then that bear
on it you can kill a bear
yeah and it's like if you're bare naked
that means you're it's obvious everyone
can see it
um if you're burying your teeth that
means you're showing your teeth so
arms would be like open carry basically
well that's what we think
today in 2021 with that word but i'd be
curious to think what to know what their
definition of it was
in 17 you can look at a lot of the
quotes from the founding fathers and
like the federalist papers and things
like that and they're pretty much like
everybody should have guns all the time
right people had people at artillery
you know they had private artillery at
their at their homes there's like a
funny meme about
some you know the people a lot of people
on the left like to say
you know the founding fathers didn't
expect someone have a semi-automatic you
know whatever ar-15 assault weapon or
something
um which assault weapon is meaningless
by the way but uh and then there's this
funny meme where it's like
someone breaks into a guy's house and he
pulls out his musket and fires
it it goes across the street and hits a
dog ripping a hole in it because it's
smooth bore
he runs upstairs and screams tally ho
lads and then fires two massive
artillery kit like no no no
people like the the this back in the day
they had private warships
like you could literally own your own
battleship you couldn't own a cannon
you could own a cannon no you couldn't
donate cannon they actually had some
believe it or not you know i researched
this extensively because i i was always
a real 2a extreme i would say i was an
extremist
uh back i had and i maybe just barely
converted
out of the extremism but i used to say
if the government can own it
i want to be able to own it yes right
but then i realized there's
i wouldn't be able to own all the the
weapons the government has because i
don't have enough money
and do i really want the people who are
really rich to have the ability
right and then then i said okay maybe
i'm not so extreme after all because i
don't know if i want the rich
real class warfare there right i don't
want them to own the nuke
right right right and then i you know
bill gates or whoever you want to write
and then the rest of us can't right
prevents
mercenary warfare in a lot of ways
government oversight
crazy as it is yeah so you know then i'm
less extreme but
um you can own a cannon today no you
can't you you know what
you want yeah yeah maybe what what maybe
what's the definition i guess it's a
cannon
yeah it depends but back then you
couldn't have like an actual cannon
just like they banned uh fully automatic
rifles after the valentine's day
massacres
what was that other than 20s oh actually
on valentine's day
it was yeah i think it was it was a mom
mafia yeah mom hit
went in and killed like 14 or 15. i'm
thinking
maybe because we don't live on the
frontier anymore we don't need
the full open bearing arms mentality
i don't think the canon thing is
accurate i mean i did i did look it up
and there are people saying you could
not but privateers and corsairs existed
they and they maybe if it was like a
well-regulated militia could have a
candidate no but a private tier was like
it it literally means private [ __ ] it's
like private tv
yeah yeah they they they're not
necessarily pirates but they were
responsible for a lot of the piracy
because what would happen is
uh with with the uk with the with the
english crown for instance they would
issue
letters they would issue letters of mark
to a private warship
or a private ship that had military
capabilities and then the letter of mark
was basically like
if you screw with our enemies
then you're all good and then what would
happen is france would be
like they would go to the you know
britain and be like your
your your citizens are our pirates and
your signing letters of mark and then
the crown would be like oh heavens we
they're criminals we had nothing to do
with this
so it was it was it was like mercenary
warfare essentially but people had them
and maybe there's only specific cases
you could have the cannon
like if you had a ship maybe i mean that
was it but you couldn't have one in your
backyard or on your
farm i know today that like uh luke
recently sent me
a um a i guess it was like an artillery
gatling gun of some sort
with like it's got two wheels and it's
this massive thing i sent you a tommy
gun
you're not allowed to have that well not
full auto but you can have it you can
have a tommy gun yeah
um but there's gatling guns are legal
gatling gun's totally legal so each
crank is a trigger pull so you're
allowed to go
and so he's like showing me this like
rotating nine millimeter or whatever
with these huge magazines he's like i
think you should get this and i'm like
bro
i don't think i need i don't think i
need that
why not you never know steven crowder
did like a big thing about this about
what the founding fathers thought and
expected when it came to weapons and
what were available at the time
and i guess a lot of a lot of people you
know these these liberals who
interestingly now are the ones who are
very much so buying a lot of these
weapons
that there were very serious
technological advancements in terms of
firearms back in the day they just
weren't common so while people were
using like flintlock pistols and muskets
and stuff there were
there i think there was one like he
showed where it's got like 16 barrels
and they were each loaded and you could
like fire them all rep in succession and
those were legal and allowed
it's just people it was easier and
cheaper to have the standard
you know single shot or whatever so i
guess
it is interesting argument about what
they actually thought but
as far as i can tell you know maybe
maybe by today's standards the founding
fathers would look and be like oh
heavens people have
like how did they change this yet but
hold on
that would that would apply to
everything else too like okay well then
you don't have free speech on social
media
you don't you know you're not allowed to
use telephones because like
the the idea that you aren't allowed to
have your first amendment rights your
right to worship because technology
changed
you know well beyond what they expected
to happen communications over the
internet is not guaranteed
and i guess they're arguing that to a
certain extent but
no like technology changes but our
rights change with them so a better
example is probably the fourth amendment
metadata if you are you have private
information you do not expect people to
see
then it is a violation of of your your
uh rights
to illegally search and or seize your
private information
there was no such thing as metadata back
then but we still i think
for the most part agree the nsa is bad
you know
spying on us and stealing our data is a
violation of our right to be
free from this intrusion and so
when it comes down to the constitution i
actually think
there are some things that we we don't
want even the state to use against its
people or the people to have
because weapons are becoming extremely
powerful particularly directed energy
weapons
cat's out of the bag though there's two
big points the constitution is there
and just because i might not agree with
it i i don't feel like i have the right
to
do you have the right to amend it i have
the right to to express my opinion like
i'm doing now
but i don't i don't believe that these
these politicians who are passing these
laws have a right to do that unless they
amend the constitution
so by all means we can have a
conversation but if you don't get that
two-thirds majority then
it should not be done question is should
we amend it at this point it doesn't
matter
what do you mean 3d printed guns like
there's no stopping but should we have
the right to bear
arms should everyone have the explicit
right to walk around with the open carry
weapon
yup even in a city where you're packed
together and it's like
20 30 people sitting on a bus and
everyone's got a handgun yep
very polite maybe not a handgun oh yeah
i think so you think so
everything anything i really i think you
can have like
what about if a little kid had one what
about if a kid reached over and grabbed
your gun or something
that's theft but it was a kid it didn't
know any better what would you do
what if like someone's four-year-old
reached over and tried to grab your gun
then take better care of your gun and
maybe just out of your holster just
reach over and grab your whole head and
get it yeah make sure you save something
what would you do would you shoot a kid
like what are you doing no
wait wait wait wait wait what would some
crazy person get away from my
arm it's a four-year-old and you what if
it's like an 11 year old
that you'd grab are you you can't
overpower 11 year old ian
of course let me get to the point i'm
just saying you're getting
i'm saying so long as the constitution
says you have the right to keep and bear
arms
i can't tell someone they can't do it i
know but should we change the
constitution is my question
like do you think there should be
training for guns you know this is like
one
maybe a lot saying okay you can yes
absolutely
you can but what about if we said okay
you can bear it publicly
as long as you've passed training
courses the the i i don't like that idea
why not i guess the challenge is so long
as the constitution has it
verbatim in there i feel like it would
be
an authoritarian violation of other
people's rights to supersede the supreme
law of this land
that includes all of the amendments as
well like fifth amendment fourth
amendment third i don't think we have to
worry about the third amendment because
troops aren't gonna be coming to our
houses but you know you know whatever we
don't know that i mean look what they're
doing
i know for real third amendment might be
covered might become important
i i used to actually think more along
the lines of there's probably reasonable
restrictions we can put in place
and you know much like the first
amendment i think there are some
reasonable interpretations
don't commit a crime so with the first
amendment we have a right to free speech
freedom of assembly
religion the press and a region of
grievances and those are all fairly
straightforward and we know what they
can do and what we can do and
if someone commits a crime by
instructing or inciting violence
that is not protected in fact it says
peaceably assemble
and so that i understand that's not in
my opinion a restriction on the first
amendment which says speech and
and reason and peaceably assemble if you
are committing a crime
there is a challenge because crimes can
cr laws can be changed and
other things can become crimes they can
say okay
if you one of the arguments to be
careful of and this is why i'm i'm still
very much more absolute on free speech
issues
not completely though is they'll say all
right if
committing a crime is the threshold by
which you don't have the right to say
something like telling someone to go
commit
harm or murder somebody charles manson
then what if they pass a law saying hate
speech is a crime and now they can say
okay well now that offending someone is
a crime you can't cross the threshold of
committing a crime so it's
it's very difficult and that's why the
constitution exists for
an important reason the founding fathers
were very concerned about tyranny
more so the bill of rights was the
anti-federalists who are concerned that
centralization of federal authority
would cause another situation like they
had with the crown
so we got these guaranteed rights if you
want them to change we have an amendment
process for this
so as much as i might be like in chicago
we got gun problems
in new york you know we had when we were
talking with luke about this it was
interesting because i said
bro if you're in a cubicle apartment
stacked on top of a bunch of concrete
shoe boxes smelling like sour milk
and someone breaks in and you've got you
know like a 308 rifle
you're going to go through the walls you
might hit somebody that's really bad and
luke's instinctive reaction was maybe we
ban
you know maybe we don't allow certain
calibers i was like oh there it is
it's exactly exactly the logic people
use and i totally understand it
if you're in new york and someone tries
robbing you and you part your gun
you can cause a lot of collateral damage
because you're prob
you'll probably miss people don't
realize even people who are good at
shooting might be in an intense
situation
they're they panic they miss they hit
something they hit somebody else
so naturally people in big city say we
want gun control laws
my problem is okay but you need to amend
the constitution
we can't just say the constitution is
meaningless because either it matters or
it doesn't
and i do not believe that i
have the authority or any politician
does to be like constitution doesn't
matter i guess that's why we don't why
the constitution says anyone can do it
and then it's like a state by state or
locality by locality
thing because you don't want to ban the
open right to carry in
you know rural idaho when just because
the new york city is too clo people are
too close together
but we don't do that with free speech we
don't say well it's based on which city
you live in
so you know you should have the right to
say what you want to say if you're in
rural idaho but not if you're in new
york city i mean we you know so on that
point
we don't have it municipality by
municipality we do it
you know it's a blanket free speech
maybe the issue is just listen you're
responsible for whatever comes at the
end of that barrel
and if you live in new york and you own
a gun and you have it on you and you use
it and whatever it hits you're
responsible for
the same is true for anywhere you live
yeah but if i'm dead i'm not gonna care
how responsible you were held
to whatever it was right like at that
point i'm already
i've already been victimized or i've
already had to
take the bullet literally and you maybe
get punished but what does that do
to help me and i think that's why you
know they make these laws because
they're trying to prevent
from me ever having that situation not
it's not about
you won't get punished it's about i
won't be victimized
it's a it's a it's it's an ethical
conundrum to say the least and uh
man we just really love really love
making sure everybody knows who michael
malus is
yeah i hope you talk about me as well
you know as much
as i got he's just got these really good
points
my rights are not up to a vote and i'm
like
man but they are aren't they you can
vote to amend the constitution and
change people's
rights so the issue is yes but i think
the
the the simple simple way to look at it
is so long as the constitution
guarantees your right to bear
arms to keep them then then it needs to
be all the states coming together and
changing that
and not some rep kinzinger in illinois
being like i think we should have
expanded background checks banning the
private sale of firearms so do you
agree with banning certain weapons or
all weapons from those who've committed
absolutely not so even those who've
committed violent crime
with weapons and then they get out of
jail they pay the debt to society
and so you think they should be allowed
to own a weapon again yes
even those who committed violent crime
with a gun they're out of prison
yeah so they paid the debt to society
well
maybe they should be allowed to vote
they should yeah i agree
they should get all of their rights
reinstated all of them including wow the
right to bear arms i don't know i hadn't
thought about that i mean i definitely
think felons who've who've paid their
price and have come out should have the
right restored to
vote and bear arms and travel everything
yeah everything
except i don't know about whether or not
you know domestic violence
especially guys that have committed acts
of domestic violence they go in they
come out
and they serve very little time and then
you know so not everybody does pay
what i would consider a reasonable debt
to society it is better that 10 guilty
persons escaped than one innocent person
suffer
i will take the the liberty-based view
that we must protect the the rights of
the individual the
and and those who have done right by our
system and our rules
over fear that there may be a risk like
uh it we mentioned this the other day i
think it was
otto von bismarck or whatever who said
it is better that 10 innocent people
suffer than one guilty person escaped
somebody who's suicidal what do you
think
should they have the right to bear arms
yes even if you know
i'm in favor of assisted suicide yeah
but this is different than assisted
suicide this is somebody who's
um you know down they're feeling very
down they
they're not seeing the the light at the
end of the tunnel right they're feeling
and this is something that could be
corrected fixed but not if they have a
shotgun
not if they have a butter knife but i
agree with you on you know on uh
physician-assisted suicide for sure that
happens you see the
the dark knight you know the batman
movie yeah joker made a pencil disappear
you know that scene it's a very brutal
scene where he goes into the mobsters
and
they're like what do you want he's like
i'm going to show you something i'm
doing a magic trick and he's oh right
i'm going to make it disappear and then
he slams the guy's head into it the
pencil is gone
the reason i bring that up is like if
somebody if somebody is determined to
cause themselves harm and end their life
what they need
is help and i one of the reasons i'm in
favor of assisted suicide is not because
i'm like yes someone should just help
them die it's because they'll talk to
somebody first
they'll go through a process to make
sure they actually it's actually
something that should happen
and oftentimes a lot of people might
have a chronic disease or like cluster
headaches
where their life is just pure psychotic
misery and agony and they're desperate
nothing will relieve their pain
oftentimes they're going through a
period of depression and it'll put it'll
help them go through therapy as opposed
taking their taking their taking action
on their own the the gun argument for
suicide overlooks the fact that
people will get drunk and then sink into
a bathtub or they'll take pills and then
sink into a bathtub
drop a toaster in the bathtub and a
bunch of other really awful things
well i don't know i think you know for a
lot of people they're they maybe want to
end their life but they want to do it
quick and easy and they can't
fathom doing it in some you know drawn
out way that's going to cause
a lot more pain or harm they want
something quick um
and you know that's going to be good
right it does and it and it is the
number one you know when
people talk about all the gun violence
right whenever they're mentioning all
the gun violence all these things it's
mostly suicide
that's true and so that's true so maybe
there should be some sort of provision
where it is like a seven
year you know that's what california
does seven years you can't own a weapon
after ever been suicidal or an attempt
right after
for seven years i think that's way too
long way too long
yeah it might be long yeah that might be
a bit prison's intense though the way
our prison structure is is it makes
people
radicalize oh absolutely the most part
so a gun violent a
violent gun offender goes in there comes
out the good chance that
he or she is crazier than they were when
they went in so the the main issue the
suicide thing is
i'll put it this way i would absolutely
love it if there was a way to reasonably
have someone who was suicidal not have
access to
a gun or something they could use to end
their life one of the reasons i'm in
favor of assisted suicide
is that we want to encourage as many
people to go to go to a doctor and for
therapy
to talk about why they feel this way and
determine if it actually is something
they should
they need most people oh so you mean
you're for physician-assisted suicide
even if the person's healthy
and they want to end their life no no
i'm saying it would encourage people who
are suicidal to go to a doctor and then
the doctor would be like no
you know what i mean i don't know if i
mean if they
unless they were led to believe that
that was an option like if i can go to
my doctor and i could tell him i'm
suicidal i don't want to do this anymore
help me
yeah yeah but that's different than like
well so there would be criteria but i do
believe there are a lot of people who
would be like my life sucks i'm
miserable and i think i might qualify
they'll go to a doctor
whatever weekend they have to be crazy
and suicidal i think
i think it's it's it may not be a
perfect solution but whatever we can do
to encourage people who are suffering to
go to a doctor yeah in any capacity
right right so
i would love it if we could be like okay
let's they can't if they're dead because
they've shot themselves because we'll
let them have a gun
then how do you take away their gun
before they were suicidal
before you knew they were supposed to
well you didn't right so they had the
option at that point and so we're not
not it's definitely not going to cure
the problem
well because people usually reach out at
some point prior to that point i mean
most people don't
really want to end their life and so
they go through a process of reaching
out before they get to that point so the
people around them
know and then they can say we're going
to take the weapon you're talking just
if they've attempted suicide no or
they've reached out and said i'm
not you know because they go through a
process prior to even hitting that point
there was a there was a story i think
this was in maryland i'm not sure it
might have been baltimore area
where there was a guy he was in his 60s
and i could be getting some of the
details wrong but
the gist of it was someone in his life
an axe or a family member was feuding
with them
told the police that he was unstable and
unwell and armed
and so they served a red flag warrant
the police were up to his house and he
had no idea why they were there
they knock on the door and he answers
the door and he's got his gun
which he's legally allowed to do and
they said
we are taking your gun and he doesn't
know why
and he said the hell you are and he
fought with them and they shot and
killed him
the problem with trying to seize
someone's weapons because
we think they might be suicidal is that
we create conflicts where someone with a
gun is now going to be engaging with
police
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you